Where should I. Should I go?
Should we do chicken legs?
Yes, chicken legs.
A Sing Squad listener wrote in and said,
what is the actual definition of exclusive?
Option A is exclusivity means
exclusivity equals boyfriend and girlfriend. Like.
Or is do you wanna be exclusive?
Option B, do you wanna be exclusive means, yeah,
I wanna be exclusive. That's a buffer time
where we're deciding if we wanna be boyfriend and girlfriend.
I think it's option A.
I think exclusivity equals boyfriend and girlfriend
at my geriatric age and I'm option B.
I think you.
There's like a buffer period where you're figuring out of your.
While you're exclusive and then you become boyfriend girlfriend.
So we. Let us know what you think.